so at this point how do you feel about
your addiction it's kind of hard for me
to say that I feel like I have spent a
lot of money you feel you have an
attention yeah I do have an addictive
personality but when I think about a
drug addict I guess I don't think about
myself it's perfectly normal to be on
the fence about whether you are or are
not an addict but the first thing we
have to get to is for you to begin to
accept that you are an addict
like I was managing every day but I knew
to manage and get up and do anything to
do that dope had to be there when I was
that make sense now managing your
addiction I was yet to be able to
function but acceptance of your
addiction comes in layers starting with
first your ability to admit you are the
Attic and you can't go anywhere until
you do in your case the cocaine crack
when you got in those hotel rooms one
day went to another day I mean yes
pretty much
I would going like binges if that make
sense like you maybe a pinch like couple
days and then take a very cruel oh boy
we take a break flight three or four
days and then I took a break for like
three weeks and then I took a break for
another week you know what I mean
was it taking up more of your time oh
yeah
what were you gonna say before that like
my kidneys and my liver has kind of been
effective mm-hmm
you're taking care of yourself has
certainly been affected well yeah but I
mean let's say this ain't broke because
of coke crack cocaine is Bocage most mi
huh but again your willingness to take
aside the money that would have took to
fix it as opposed to buying the crack
you decided now I'd rather have the
crack then fix my tooth yeah I'm pretty
much home
how was home looking was home in
disarray was home okay everybody mm I
mean a bit like I said it wasn't like it
was a reg people in recovery have to
gain the trust of their loved ones what
would you tell not like the family
relations issues with Gino tension I
mean that was that was the main thing
that was it honestly the main reason why
I want about to use this why I could for
nine months and I didn't want to deal
with what was going on between me and
him and so I thought I would and it kind
of like the feelings I was having it
just using the cocaine just kind of blew
that filling up like it made it worse
you you smoked at hope with the intent
to forget it may feel better but what
actually happened was you became what
they saw which was erratic out of
control maybe more aggressive which is
an effect from the substance their
substance has now become the priority
over every person and everything and
every object in the world that we care
about and right now that's very much
what you're saying it has now become top
dog
[Music]
so I'm gonna ask you again are you an
addict
[Music]